anu kumari once hoped to get a
high-paying job in the indian railways
she's been preparing for entrance exams
in this hostel she shares with others
it's been five years and now anu says
she'll accept any job offer private
sector what can we do kovid has wiped
out private jobs in any case there were
few companies in our state we've always
counted on government jobs if this
doesn't work out i will have to get
married and sit at home
this burning train in the eastern state
of bihar is a sign of india's
unemployment crisis 12 million people
applied for 35 000 railway jobs some of
them set it on fire after the government
changed its recruitment rules
nearly 1 in 12 indians is out of work
nationwide the young and educated are
struggling nearly half the population
under 30 with a college degree does not
have a job the pandemic recovery has
been uneven job losses and price rise
have pushed millions of people into
poverty but the indian stock market has
soared and the rich have become even
wealthier
the finance minister says the government
will spend billions of dollars to
improve infrastructure and create more
jobs the overall sharp rebound and
recovery of the economy is reflective of
our country's strong recipients
india's economic growth in the current
year is estimated to be 9.2 percent
highest among all large economies
special in terms but experts say her
budget speech did little to address
india's economic crises and it's not
just about pandemic right there has been
a slowdown pre-pandemic as well so this
was a budget which could have addressed
both the issue of decline in output in
general because of the pandemic but also
the slow growth
the government says the economy will
grow at about eight percent next year
many job seekers like anu hope this will
mean more employment opportunities
al jazeera new delhi